Attendez les mecs, euh...
Séduire une fille, à un premier rendez-vous, c'est hyper facile !
Ah, faux ! *musique coréenne connue*
Quand tu fais un premier rendez-vous avec une meuf,
t'as toujours envie que le premier regard, tout de suite, soit stylé.
*Musique stylée*
Waouh...
Salut
Salut baby
T'sais, on a pas envie que la première image qu'elle ait de nous,
soit une image parfaitement ridicule.
Putain de merde, put...
Ah salut !
Ce... ça va bien?
Ramener un bouquet de fleurs, à un premier rendez-vous...
Bon, c'est un petit peu romantique.
Mais, perso, moi j'trouve ça un tout petit peu ringard
Et en plus, on comprend directement tes intentions, tu vois?
Attends c'est pour moi les fleurs?
T'as cru qu'il allait se passer un truc entre nous?
T'as cru qu'on allait se pécho?
*rires*
Euh nan nan... ça c'est, c'est, c'était juste des fleurs d'amitié.
*pleurs de bébé*
Moi j'pense qu'il y a un truc qui doit être pas mal pour séduire une meuf,
c'est de faire comme dans les films américains :
C'est de venir la chercher chez elle
euh, en véhicule,
pour l'emmener sur le lieu du rendez-vous.
Tu vois, c'est classe !
Encore faut-il avoir... un... un véhicule.
Ah, t'es venu me chercher, c'est cool.
C'est toi dans la voiture ?
*au téléphone* Ah nan...
Ah, c'est toi sur le scooter, là.
*au téléphone* Nan nan...
Ah oui, c'est bon...
Je te vois là...
J'ai deux tickets de bus !
Je t'invite !
Sinon, si tu veux, moi j'ai 16 000 skates.
Hein, des skates, euh...
deux places !
Le premier endroit où t'emmènes une fille,
c'est hyper important parce que ça montre un petit peu tes goûts,
ton univers !
Moi je sais jamais où aller pour paraître stylé.
T'sais, j'ai toujours peur que ce soit glauque.
*bruit d'entrechoquement*
Dans les yeux !
Et donc toi tu viens souvent dans des PMU ?
Euh nan, c'est la première fois...
Mais je pensais que ça serait p'têt une bonne idée.
Un p'tit tiercé ?
Bah non.
Pour un premier rendez-vous, c'est pas mal de s'habiller un peu classe, un peu élégant, tu vois ?
P'tite chemise,
p'tite cravate,
p'tit veston,
p'tit slip !
Mais comme moi, j'suis pas habitué à mettre des chemises ou tes vêtements classes,
Bah dès que je le fais pour un premier rencard
J'ai l'impression d'en faire des tonnes !
J'suis vraiment désolé, j'suis venu complètement à l'arrache, j'ai pas eu le temps de m'habiller, j'ai mis n'importe quoi.
Ah t'inquiète pas ! C'est cool.
Un tiercé ?
T'façons, quand tu prends un premier verre avec une fille et qu'il y a un petit feeling,
tu le sais tout de suite.
Et quand il y a pas de... de feeling,
bah tu le sais aussi.
Excusez-moi, je crois pas que je sois une pastèque avec des lunettes, hein !
Parce que moi,
c'est Batman !
*rires*
C'est incroyable ! Moi aussi j'viens du sud.
Ah bon ?
Mais oui, jusqu'à mes 16 ans !
Ah c'est fou !
Ça m'arrive rarement de croiser des gens du sud.
*rires* J'passe une trop bonne soirée !
Faut faire attention parce que, moi des fois, quand j'suis à un premier rendez-vous,
et que j'suis un peu intimidé par la fille,
des fois,
j'fais genre de l'écouter, alors qu'en fait j'écoute même pas ce qu'elle dit.
Ils allaient pour traverser et, comme ils étaient aveugles, ils ont pas vu le camion arriver et...
c'est comme ça que mes parents sont morts.
*rires*
Énorme !
Bon !
On va chez toi ?
Quand tu veux séduire, même le plat que tu choisis c'est important.
T'sais, tu peux pas manger un truc nul.
Moi j'vais prendre : une choucroute XXL,
avec le supplément pied de porc,
Euh, en entrée, bah des rillettes de cervelas.
Mmmh...
Et, euh, et puis un pastis, hein.
Et puis les p'tites cahuètes gratuites
si possible.
Tu veux quoi?
Non c'est bon j'ai pas faim.
J'vais te regarder manger en fait.
Moi, quand j'suis à un premier rendez-vous,
il y a tellement de stress, tellement de pression,
que, des fois, quand j'fais une petite pause, pour aller aux toilettes deux minutes,
j'ai l'impression d'être entre deux rounds de match de boxe.
Allez mon gars !
T'es bien parti.
Là, t'es au top, ok ?
Là, tu te laisses pas faire, hein ?
Si elle te pose une question, tu réponds tout de suite, ok ?
Attends, attends... Fais voir ?
Y'a pas de salade, c'est bon.
Bon, sèche-toi les mains, on est reparti !
C'est pas grave, t'es un champion, allez vas-y fonce !
Ça va Norman ?
Bah ouais.
Qu'est-ce qui y'a ?
Au moment de payer l'addition, à un premier rendez-vous
Bon, c'est plutôt le garçon qui invite.
Sauf que, si tu veux rester classe en payant l'addition,
il faut rester assez discret quand tu regardes le prix.
Voici l'addition monsieur.
Merci.
*ils discutent*
Ouah ! Ouho ! Ok ! Ok...
Pour que ce soit classe de payer l'addition,
il faut que tu restes naturel.
Comme si, euh... Rien ne t'avait choqué.
Voici l'addition monsieur.
Merci.
*ils discutent*
*dans ses pensées* Wouah putain c'est cher de ouuuuf !
*dans ses pensées* C'est un truc de malade comment c'est cher !
*dans ses pensées* J'vais devoir payer tout ça ?!
*dans ses pensées* J'espère vraiment qu'à ce prix là, on va rentrée chez elle et qu'elle va me *bip*
Evidemment l'idéal, quand tu sors d'un premier rendez-vous avec une fille,
bah c'est de finir par un doux baiser.
Mais moi, je sais jamais à quel moment me lancer.
T'sais, à quelle seconde le faire !
J'sais pas comment on peut se dire au revoir, peut être...
Euh...
J'sais pas non plus...
Bah... Au revoir !
*rire gêné*
*dans ses pensées* Ah putain, je sais pas quand y aller...
*dans ses pensées* Bon, j'y vais ou j'y vais pas là ?
*dans ses pensées* Raaah... Est-ce qu'elle veut vraiment que je le fasse ?
Embrasse-là ! Embrasse-là ! Embrasse-là !
*dans ses pensées* Bon aller, j'me lance comme un homme !
Trois !
Deux !
Un !
Aller !
Rentre bien !
En fait j'crois que, nous les mecs,
euh, parfois,
on est juste un peu con...
C'est tout.
*outro*
Ah ça va Norman ?
Ouais bof. Mon premier rendez-vous là, c'était vraiment un échec...
Du coup, je voulais savoir si tu pouvais m'héberger ?
Ouais, bien sûr. Pas de soucis, ouais.
Tiens !
C'est des fleurs d'amitié !
Allô ?
Ouais !
*claquement de porte*
Merci d'avoir regardé ma vidéo !
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à ma chaîne YouTube :
NormanFaitDesVidéos
J'ai aussi une page Facebook :
C'est toujours le même titre hein !
Toujours le même nom : NormanFaitDesVidéos
À aucun moment ça va être :
KévinFaitDuBMX
Tu vois, voilà vraiment, c'est... euh...
À noter,
dans vos agendas
Et autres euh...
Et autres i-pade (iPad).